we're talking today with James I'll and
writer pierce the cofounders of a very
interesting organization called Sherpa
share it works in the ride service
business and it provides services both
to drivers and to other people and
companies interested in this business so
we're very interested in learning more
about what you do why you founded your
organization and where it's going so
welcome thank you for joining us today
thank you thanks for having us so tell
me what is Sherpa sure what is it that
you do yeah so Shiva is a financial
management and the communication
platform for on-demand workers and we
basically offer them to access visit of
them independent and use your platform
to access information utility and the
work opportunities to maximize their
work and tell me a little bit about why
you form this organization what what led
you to do it the fundamental reason is
we see there's a you know fundamental
conflict between animal services and the
workers and workers typically working
for multiple services and they have
growing challenges to manage their work
and understand it at all the work
options and they don't have loyalty to
any services at the same time a company
are competing for the same supply pool
and they have very high equitation costs
and so we think a study party a buffer
layer in between can benefit the both
side so that's why we position are still
so that needed and so who do you define
as your customers for your services so
typically it's been rideshare drivers is
who we've started with and there's
typically uber a lift formerly sidecar
and and delivery companies as well
although we'd like to expand to other
independent drivers and do the companies
themselves come to you with ideas for
your services or
ask you for either information and
that's helpful to them as well some yeah
especially for smaller players so
basically they are looking for a channel
to acquire supplies but for the actually
for the workers they are also looking
for a study party channel to exchange
information as well yeah you know what I
find fascinating is you characterize
Sherpa share as an intermediary not as a
representative or an advocate for one
party or the other tell me more about
how that works and why your positioning
Sherpa share in this kind of middle
category what do each of the different
stakeholders get from your services yeah
so as I said like most of workers
actually working for multiple services
so because they are working for multiple
services they need tools to manage their
earnings from different sources check
their personal expenses understand that
their tax liability when navigator
increasingly more more working options
and no single animal service can
actually provide it no necessary tools
to help them and on other side is animal
services are very powerful and a worker
is actually on a weak side and they
don't they are forced into a cillo
situation so that's why we think like a
shipper share as a Saudi party can
provide about it on both sides make the
transaction more smooth and efficient
yeah for example so the the the workers
don't have loyalty as jay-z said and so
workers need a place where they can
manage their multiple work options and
also communicate with each other and
exchange information and the problem the
companies are having is they basically
don't have a good way to demand loyalty
or command loyalty and that's that's one
of the things we see they're struggling
with quite a bit how do they actually
convince a driver who has
full options to work for them and that's
in many ways the challenge of the
on-demand economy where you don't have a
direct employer and employee
relationship in place so that the the
interaction is a little bit more fluid
so I think that's a very interesting
point so your your services come via an
app take me through the app if I'm a
driver what do i do how do I get access
to it what will I learn by using your
app yeah so I was supposed to actually
have a mobile app we also have a website
so we provide a tool to help you to
consolidate all your earnings into one
place we also use a mobile app to track
your expense automatically now since
currently the will focus on the drivers
so the biggest expense for them actually
is a mileage so we track the marriage
for them automatically we also have a so
called heat map which is a cross sauce
the map show where the hot spot for the
drivers in real time so they can based
on gmaps decide when and where to work
for which service and we also have a
so-called chat feature so kind of chat
room so drivers can you know get help
get support from other drivers yeah
that's basically what we have now
actually we are launching a new app as
of last week we launched a brand new app
that basically took the chat feature and
gave it its own home so when we launched
the chat in our existing app we found
that drivers it was a strong need for
drivers to communicate with each other
to ask questions to give status updates
what's it like downtown right now for
example when is the game get out and so
last week we launched a new app
dedicated to basically allowing drivers
to exchange information yeah called a
ship a house in real time exchanged
words for example and when I came in
this morning I posted something saying
hey we're going to be in Boston talking
about driver issues anything
want us to talk about and we had several
drivers right away respond a couple cup
of the points where you know but repeat
at uber should add tips for drivers so
that was those one that drivers and
atoms add tips was the one and a few
others basically saying that drivers
want to communicate more so like if
companies can do more or if we can do
more to help drivers communicate it's a
strong need that's very interesting that
drivers are they operate independently
separately they're all in their own
vehicle and so on but they're looking
for some sense of community and
communications that's and that's a
service that you can provide that's very
interesting yeah they're like a two
fundamental need drivers need the number
one is always financial need the second
need actually we call social need so
basically they need a channel to talk
about their career and the soul facility
they talk two passages every day that
they need to talk to other drivers talk
about their company talk about their you
know so called a career in some way so
we we want to become that channel well
that's a fascinating opportunity for
people to do it in a modern way do you
know if this creates any social
networking where people drivers actually
physically get together and form
communities or is it all online it both
actually yeah there is some offline we
see more I mean online is the big one
because everyone has different schedules
and so it's hard to align but
traditional employment of course had
lunch break the break room the water
cooler which doesn't exist for the
drivers and so via I mean we would like
to replicate the online chat as that the
water cooler area we do see in some
cities where there are a lot of drivers
the drivers will coordinate hey I'm
taking a break at this coffee shop now
and and trying to get a few people
together so we so it's kind of our
platform drivers can organize whatever
they want whether that's discussions are
offline meetups another name another
name for on the amount industry some
people call Oh 20 which is a online to
offline or
to online actually our community is very
interesting we develop a community from
offline to online but eventually we also
want to bring online to offline in some
way yeah well as all kinds of
opportunities for that kind of kind of
interaction well let's let's talk more
specifically about the drivers and how
they are doing financially that you're
providing both information for helping
them build a social network but also to
assess their own financial situation
what are you hearing from drivers what
can you say about how they are doing
financially now over time yeah the
biggest thing we found at a fundamental
level was a lot of these drivers are
first-time independent workers and so
understanding expenses mileage tracking
wasn't really there so didn't have a
basis for that and so what that meant
was whatever uber and lyft and other
companies marketed to them if they say
thirty-five dollars an hour drivers
didn't have a good sense of what their
actual net earnings was and that's why
we started that's how we started
basically showing them here's what
you're actually making another issue we
saw was yeah that basically drivers
didn't know how to optimize their work
and so those are a couple things we've
helped them with and so we put our
reports every once in a while that
showed trends in different cities and we
do see that you know earnings per trip I
mean they do fluctuate so in some cities
they go up some they go down of course
people's schedules are vastly different
so it's it's always been very difficult
to 2.2 a trend in in either direction
but what I will say is that we we
noticed that the vast majority of these
workers are doing this for supplemental
income and so this might be 10 hours a
week or 20 hours a week and that's in
the range of they might make a couple
hundred dollars more in addition to
full-time work
what do you hear from the drivers
themselves what would they like Sherpa
share to do they they definitely like
always want to make more money yeah and
so whatever we do can increase the
income they will love it so we basically
organize our servicing three bucket when
the first one is help them to sort of
like a managed account their money right
managing their money second is basically
how to help them to optimize their
income the third bucket duplicity how to
help them make more money so if you look
at what services basically we provided
some personality Toolz so help them to
count their money then we'll build a
community so with some cross source the
information so they can make a better
decisions every day hopefully they can
optimize their work and maximum income
the third thing we eventually what we'll
do is connect them with new working
opportunity so we can they can make more
money yeah and so that's how what the
drivers get from you what's your revenue
mouth how do you survive and you have
investors now as a start-up organization
but you are for-profit business so
what's the model for generating revenue
yeah so we are intermediate layer
between the animal services and workers
and so we we also a layer between
workers and other worker related
services and a worker and consumer right
so we eventually will make money from
every relationship so we will start with
some premium services on the worker side
then try to make up some money on the
company side throw some marketing and VJ
and kinetics yeah so marketing
opportunities for companies and pay for
services from drivers for more premium
kind of information and
material exactly so an example of that
would be what's most valuable to drivers
now is tracking mileage because that's a
direct number they can look at and use
for tax deduction and so that's
something where a lot of other utility
services charge for and drivers are
willing to pay for so that's one example
in the worker side they'll pay for that
utility and the company side they'll see
that there's a network of drivers who
have a certain level of experience in
the space and of course those are
potential drivers that they want to
target so that's of course they're
interested in both acquiring those
drivers and then once they've acquired
them convincing them to work on a
certain day yeah so so in some respects
you can be a recruiting agency or help
them to identify the pool of potential
drivers for them so that's that's a
really important service because that
must be very difficult what what do you
find is how stable are these drivers how
long do they stay do they turn over a
lot what's what your experience telling
you there's boy there's a natural to
turn for this industry yeah and
sometimes we use a metaphor chavo
industry so moniker for the travel
industry like a like every family they
might travel two to three times a year
something like that but for this
industry more like people will aren't
off kind of thing so for us it's more
like we provide a platform with data and
information that whenever they decide to
you know do something in this industry
they will go to super share
and and hopefully you know with the
entire industry become amateur hour
later higher I think of people will find
that this is more legit viable option
for them make a living yeah yeah so an
example that would be someone who on
boards with uber for example might only
really want that income for a month or a
week even to have some type of outcome
and then leave for six months and that's
a pattern we see where people really
want someone come for a fixed period of
time and then they might leave and the
question that we're always wondering is
at and we believe at some point they'll
come back because the one extra income
it's a question of like when when's the
next phase of their of their life where
they'll need supplemental income so it
could be students is a good example
where students will on our on our way
over here we had an uber driver who was
also a full-time student and a full-time
driver and he fits in his driving when
he's a student but after he's done after
he graduates he'll probably find a
full-time job and scale back on the
driving so you fit it into sort of the
life courses people's life changes and
responsibilities change and time
allocations right and the other end is
when people are older and they have more
free time they'll also become drivers as
well there are a lot of controversies in
this industry as you know question about
whether drivers should be independent
contractors or employees concerns on
some chat rooms and various online link
linking mechanisms that uber doesn't
really care about the drivers what are
you hearing where where are you
positioned do you hear these kinds of
things do you see them as credible
what's your view of some of the
critiques of this industry at the moment
I think some concerns a true in some
degree and you know we are kind of happy
that we see some other groups supporting
workers as well and then we are very
honored to be a very important channel
for jewelry stores up their concerns we
actually want to take a new to
independent publishing I think of the
entire only my industry need protection
right so basically we definitely protect
workers but also need to protect the the
suicide so I think that the better way
is you know klaipeda beauty some
channels allow them to communicate I
think eventually they will found a
balance somewhere yeah well I think this
this role of providing information is as
a basis for fostering more
communications between all of the
parties who have a stake in this
industry is as an important service that
you're providing so help me envision
where you will be five years from now
what will shirt Bashar look like if you
are successful
we want to become the number one support
platform for animal workers around the
globe and so currently we are only focus
on the driver driver vertical only in
the US market but we want to expand to
other vertical and other regions as well
so that that's a that's weak or hope
expires yeah so basically all those
workers will be exchanging information
on our platform and so whatever whatever
service they want to work for whatever
opinion they have they'll use Sherpa
Sharra's like they're the exchange for
that information so the your point
earlier about giving them a voice is
something we really want to emphasize so
we don't necessarily care what the voice
is but we give you the channel to
basically express yourself yeah the
ultimate to vision I'm thinking is it's
more like a driver to say I have eight
hours to work and ship I sure can put up
a walking portfolio for him so he can't
hit his financial go on the daily basis
so they could look at where the optimal
opportunities are what times of day what
days of the week and how to balance that
with all of their other responsibilities
and be efficient in making those choices
well it's very interesting it's a very
creative organization we appreciate your
sharing your insights with you with us
for this course we wish you all the best
and thank you very much for taking the
time to come across the country you
don't have an uber service in the area
so I guess you had to go buy commercial
airline until you land and then you
could we didn't take over helicopter you
didn't take over helicopter well maybe
someday that that'll be part of all of
our future so thank you very much thank
you thanks